Should we actually be having in our mind
the idea of promoting democracy and not
necessarily by offering false promises
to the people,
but by taking on those who are thwarting
it or should or is it,
is it appropriate for us instead to
concentrate on very important point of
securing oil,
keeping friendly with those who can give
the oil on which our economy depends.
In other words,
have we got our ideals in the wrong
order?
Do you have a position on whether or not
we should actually possibly jeopardize
our economic health in favor of the idea
of pushing the democracy notion?
Okay.
This is a really good question because
it shows what the whole problem,
the whole problem is that we have
created a black and white world in which
we imagined that we have to choose all
the time either by being Dick Cheney and
focused on oil and oppression and
plotting up desk bots or on the other
hand Amnesty International with
absolutely no contact with the world at
all.
This is not,
this is not the choice that we face.
This is not what our diplomats are there
to do.
That's not what our international policy
is about.
We need to discover how to be
pragmatically moral,
how to be passionately moderate,
how to combine our moral instincts with
our interests and being realistic about
what we can and can't do.
The reason we let people down all the
time,
the reason we invade these countries and
create a mess,
the reason we're probably going to do it
again for the next 15 years is we have
never managed to get a mature
conversation going about what we're
actually doing and what we can do in
these countries were not able to
understand firstly that these countries
are not our countries,
that these countries do have a claim of
sovereignty,
that they have their own cultures,
their own languages,
and they don't really like foreigners
being in them and that therefore what we
do with other people's countries,
a bit like what I would do with you if
you were my friend has to be limited by
respect for other people's autonomy and
other people's choice and cannot involve
an endless oscillation between black and
white.
Assuming that the only choices we face
are either oil,
well,
the most pure conception of our in moral
GC.